you know what's up gasps prestige here
video games i'm a thing i like playing
I'm not like putting videos up about
them and today we're doing some
minecraft some urban experience and we
are going to fix or chicken coupe going
to do that first and then we're going to
go hit up some epic epic minds and look
for some good yeah first thing we are
doing is some stone fence one of them
will do now I don't do that 130 boop
boop boop yeah oh oh a little farther
than I had hoped for but it's good it's
good all right there you go 12 bang art
now we are going to go get if you're
into the series hello I like my
minecraft and I post minecraft up my
channel also some call duty but yep and
doing a lot my crap like this series and
yeah so 47 Fox we're gonna break this
tree down that he tree and then we're
going to go to our little tower here i'm
just going to hurt myself here's my food
out here
let's get water bucket all right now
here my mind so we're going to go like
this it's like boom boom boom boom all
right we're just going to bind down now
i think i'm going to set forward this so
i'll see you all in a bit
alright guys looks like we have found
some stuff so we are gonna hope I've
going out of speed mode and this creep
needs to die oh it's gonna kind of
burned alright so we can like send out a
bit music up a bit let's go Splore knew
that is dark up nope I was like oh it's
dark it's just upsetting bro are you can
won't reverse our way around little ABBA
one sec aah
he was inferred it wants them let's go
new unscented sword son oh that's this
morning stop it all the JIT we found a
dungeon bro all right i'll run around I
nope nope I think we're good from mobs
for the moment ooh nice found a dungeon
or what salute punch to buy tongue and
hoping for like some like armor mmm-hmm
take them but it makes me sad all right
um nothing like a spawner out of it or
anything so pop oh look at all that XP
now we're gonna take this mostly
cobblestone it's mostly cobblestones the
best cut stone I wanted like some horse
armor we've been legit I can get a horse
like I could ride him I'd be beautiful
all guys would be so beautiful like most
people think of it so now let's get a
top of our alright so so my school is
actually gonna be starting soon so some
was closing to an end for me I haven't
early start to school but most of you
guys I think are going if you're like
around high school elementary to high
school to college college there's a
little later but mostly everyone is
starting in the near future so I would
say all the videos are gonna slow down
but I actually did a really bad job this
summer of going hard so I do I apologize
for that i think i think of apologize
for that in previous video but I
apologize for that and I do want to go
hard I do want I want to go hard want to
go hang so I do want to go harder with
the videos so hopefully i'm going to be
posting like this more like i would post
it not as frequently do so i'll get more
views on each video but
if you guys want to watch it you'll
watch like a video days not that hard to
do I've been that with some other
youtubers and these aren't like super
long episodes hello these are super long
episodes something you guys can manage
it if I do it a day also did you tell me
if you want to every day since I guess
if everyone doesn't want them every day
I won't but that would make sense oh
when I make sense anyone wanna run for
David make sense that I wouldn't do it
oh if I were finding some previously
discovered to rain so let's stay away
from that area make it was lapis never
one I have to go look for lapis because
that's then you cannot find it and it's
impossible you never find it if you're
looking forward not looking for it can't
pick it all up this is previously
discovered oh no no no oh gosh I need a
torch up that makes sense I think
definitely take the spawning things of
this okay there we go I'm like put me
back yeah this is pre discover away from
the pre discovered we want to find new
discoveries alright so i think i was
over there right yeah oh my gosh what
what the heck was that i was out of baby
zombie
are you up his babies on it hi baby
zombie baby zombie down babies on the
down okay so this was good as well as
gone so this is B this is undiscovered
self huh you're a spitter spitter repose
me oh yeah I'm going to be trying to do
more videos Oh creeper be trying to do
more videos with called Rudy and
battlefields and ton of new games coming
out I will be doing my best to attempt
to post them daily like so obviously I'm
not gonna be posting every single thing
Dave I can't get three videos a day
because not wings a redemption and not
doing this to make it my job so and I've
school and stuff so I cannot just oh
hello here's some armored up balls as a
little loud I so I can't do like go
crazy hard but maybe like a video i have
a video every day at least of something
and then little bit out that would be
pretty legit so i'll do my best at that
I'll start trying to do it with ease I
start like I start schooling like
thursday and i'm recording this on
monday yeah that's right so things will
get crazy but i started youtube going
into my last to school like last year
not my final year i started youtube
going into the previous year school and
I was able to do a fine so I think I can
do it obviously i'll be doing a lot more
than you did before but we can do we got
this as long as you guys keep giving me
the motivation i can do this for a long
time i can go hard go hard bro
and my mouth ya mouth feels like it's
like Rev i like i like when you get dry
it's like drink you want to drink water
or something the water doesn't really
work I just had lunch I drink a lot of
water after that so I don't know why and
it really sounds like there is a zombie
dungeon near me sounds like everyone's
above me might wait a little bit we're
gonna say oh it's like the top of how
there we go hello boys Oh yep that is
everybody and that is everybody oh gosh
oh god no no no no no death death death
come on oh oh spreader can't face but it
can fit gosh why were there so many mugs
there's more more he goes does it ton of
moms oh gosh mom party up in this like
tiny love Kevin we pick up a block so
scary so skur think we can Oh ravine so
yes we're being means give us a chance
to get to other stuff pick that stuff up
gimme can be you me give me give me give
me feel great yeah jingle of a
restaurant there nothing you probably
know my sister like out of fortress dang
I am alright would and then we have that
I'm get all them sticks I'm complying
combine that combine that with the coal
that legit all right
hmm how to go about never really know
how to like search through a search
through like a ravine it's like hard to
do you want to see everything but it's
like a little dark oh I might have
always wanted there hmm looks like a
pretty small ravine let's place you down
hmm we have we have that let's use that
which I placing someone our way down oh
oh oh oh that doesn't work oh oh gosh no
no no light light light light okay okay
okay up no no no no no and the water
versus skeleton not a good idea o gold
legit are you ready whoa oh that is a
bow nice that water is like sand water
like beach water it's not just random
water like it spawned because you see
that there's pieces of sand who lack
it's not nice that ain't nice I'm not
picking up in there drop some
cobblestone yeah we gotta get the gold
good get the margarine I'm still just
thinking about the things about calling
it butter and stuff so that's why
cultivar different thing margins are
getting for so obvious like ploy and not
doing butter but it's funny it's funny
to me was this this is a giant Kevin o.o
who's son Oh dodged son oh alright in a
little way down now you're down there Oh
death ya creep got nothing this it was
Kelly tour thing is there's another
creeper
yeah it's time I creeper let's go
Skeletor think he should be dead all
right let's go yeah no one else yet
kripa go creeps let's go creeps let's go
to pond me nope you gonna kill me like
that kelso [ __ ] that just gives a [ __ ]
i love the driving a lot of boobs and
i'm not paying them up but because i
love spin into her nope nothing over
here just gravel way away away good whoo
it's the same ravine well I different
ravine legit I like this for being a lot
more to Ray
hmm i think oversee zombies so I'm just
burnin like a blob uh another ravine are
we going to that we're going after we go
to this ravine whoo all right I'm just
drop it stack Kabul so I can pick up
these words down we go eat some of this
and I'm going to want to block this off
look I'm going to sit in yeah yeah let's
see how that works get back you block
block block block block should be good
more gold Oh we'll take that look I'm
not gold we'll take that margarine some
redstone
put the route 202 so I feeling I have a
feeling like we won't be using our
heaven friend lunch because he's like
very deadly like it makes sense that
heroines deadly but no no he just seems
to have a liking to killing us or
tending to kill us but I'm not that
about him yet cuz I'm to suave wash on I
think we'll we can go ahead that other
ravine and then we'll call it a bid yeah
move somewhere that redstone emitter its
own son Oh more yes also it's very good
for XP all we could make a little 13
Chapman soon I've spent on a sword
everything else pending on a sword hello
zombies let me just make this a little
safer for myself yeah that's much better
it's a little bit darker but it's my
super myself die zombie hmm
I was gonna wear enter quantity oh you
soon I'm like well maybe I want to own
ship to see if I can see any diamond
since this is a low level before I go up
there then what do I find I find
diamonds okay okay make sure no mobs are
gonna ambush me gets lapis so we could
fully appreciated down fine oh my gosh
okay we're finding all the diamonds all
right so we can get rid of this egg
string mmm rotten flesh this Kabul all
right now we're good our diamonds ooh
one down will two down out where that
can make sure it's safe
okay safe our three diamonds not bad
make sure there's nothing else I think
we're good we're good we're good other
there's two lava so I don't like fall
and I all right these get any paints
still not intense hmm all right now
where did I like see that other ravine
there it is also more margarine up
creeps out Skeletor I can hit you too
son I'm quits the margarine ar.drone i
think huh there we go
oh this was another ravine I think is
just either additionally of the ravine
or nothing more well we found diamonds
out of it man this music is getting loud
ooh some powerful music move me to tears
let's go for behind me who lag hopefully
with the new can be thought I won't get
like glad with you that although we lost
the booze ok let's see ok level 30 and
the video off yes Oh nope nope nope oh
oh gosh oh gosh oh this is legit and
someone's like one sec oh this musics
too powerful their touch it's a little
more bearable ok how the heck no no let
me I want to get back up there when I go
back up there are so I'm gonna hope that
I don't get killed by a skeleton
I'll say one sec one sec one sec we're
gonna eat some food we're gonna TP oh
dope oh gosh we're just kidding on sore
from bro oh you're right you were like
one in louisville 30 oh gosh oh and
someone's going to have pick out our so
just gonna have like say like the idea
that's gonna happen ever since that are
we found ourselves a mine shaft okay
well let's see if we can get back to it
okay it can't be above me so below me
there we go I don't give so far in how a
legit we found a mine shaft oh we're
totally gonna get horse armor alright
guys hope you enjoy the video if you
creeper look at that it's a snipe area
if you have make sure you leave it a
like rate comment or subscribe if you're
new to this and you like this kind of
stuff and make sure you leave your
subscribe since I do more of this and
yeah i think if you got this far in the
video you must have liked it unless
you're like waiting here to hold on to
hate hate on me so i hope you enjoyed
i'm gonna see well next time we're going
to explore more of this all epic mind
shift almost all the routes the route
and yeah our guys peace
me